la pièce essentielle du puzzle
mythologique qu'il créerait badreddine
alain et lui a les pharaons se retrouve
dans la bibliothèque du collège mont
saint louis c'est un moment spécial pour
moi parce que j'ai étudié ici cinq ans
vous aussi pour moi c'est ici que tout a
commencé
mais pour vous aussi d'une certaine
façon non dans cette bibliothèque mais
c'est drôle parce qu'on sait jamais
croisés à l'époque puis on s'y croisent
aujourd'hui comme quoi les livres nous
ramène toujours un peu ado on vient oui
le collège mont saint louis pour moi ça
a été le début de tout si on veut je le
raconte dans mes secret mais le danger
avant d'arriver le chalet même pas en
fait que j'avais des origines étrangères
jusqu'à un certain point parce que à mon
école primaire j'étais donc avec des
fils d'émigrants des migrantes et
caetera et là j'arrive ici et là bam
tout d'un coup je réalise que j'ai pas
les mêmes chaussures que les autres que
mes cheveux sont un petit peu quitte
répu puis je vais dire quelque chose de
grave mais qu'une table des ethnies et
puis à ce moment là aussi c'est
tellement un choc et puis ma réaction
c'est de vouloir jusqu'à 120 points me
rapprocher de la majorité et donc tout
ce travail là pour moi ça a été un
travail jusqu'à un certain point de
réinvention de qui j'étais sans réaliser
que ce qu'on laisse de côté finit
toujours par nous rattraper nos racines
nos origines exactement exactement oui
puis ça m'a pris du temps à comprendre
et puis-je contente d'être allé jusqu'au
bout de l'expérience dans mille secret
mille dangers que l'exclusion le racisme
ça on se le fait subir à soi même aussi
un donc on peut aussi décider qu'on ne
compte qu on ne veut pas faire partie de
ces communautés là jusqu'à ce qu'on
réalise qu'il ya une violence le inouïe
et donc de développer en fait une
identité ça passe et je te sentes un
point par le fait de changer d'accent je
peux pas changer mon nom je serai pas
changé la manière dont je m'habillais
jusqu'à un certain point mais il ya eu
cette envie lot de pouvoir avoir les
mêmes privilèges que les autres et donc
je ne réalisais pas l'époque c'était la
mauvaise décision dans un sens c'était
la décision que j'ai prise mais il y en
a d'autres qui faisait un autre chemin
en toute sérénité mais et en même temps
l'écriture m'a permis de comprendre ce
mille secrets mais le danger c'est
l'histoire d'alain ferrand qui vit le
jour de ses noces à l'oratoire saint
joseph
et puis qui a fait revisite son passé et
dans votre livre vous parlez de monsieur
show way qui était notre enseignant de
latin mon chou me dit louis-philippe si
un jour tu veux devenir un homme il faut
que tu lises l'odyssée d'homère alors
qu'est ce que monsieur chaud vous a dit
à vous pour que vous devez n'est ni
grand garçon un professeur de
littérature
il me dit deviens ce que tu es aussi
simple que ça il m'a dit j'ai confiance
en toi tout thème la culture pita
culturel est faite de toutes sortes de
choses puis les jeux vidéo c'est ta
culture la télé c'est ta culture puis
deviens ce que tu es puis écrit puis m'a
encouragé à écrire dans notre journal
étudiant qu'on avait à l'époque et puis
m'ont soutenu donc c'est ce qui rend
aussi son destin si si tragique pour moi
puisque il est décédé quelques semaines
après la fin d'un mât graduation edouard
s'engage à surco des neiges direction
sud mais il était ailleurs ils
réécrivent l histoire manipuler le temps
reconfigurer les causes et les effets et
justement dans mes secrets ville
d'angers vous est traversé par deux
douleurs ou cette peine d'amour avec
constance et puis aussi ses maux de
ventre vous assaille constamment et j'ai
un peu l'impression dans votre livre que
cette douleur qui vous a permis tel un
phénix de renaître de vos sens un peu ça
rimbaud dirigeants se vit les morts dans
mon ventre donc cette idée là que et
puis on observe aujourd'hui à toutes
sortes d'études sont en train de définir
le fait que justement le le ventre c'est
un lieu aussi ou émotivement ya beaucoup
de choses qui se joue donc j'ai
l'impression en fait que ça m'a appris à
développer en fait une sorte de
sensibilité et puis ça a pris du temps à
trouver une surface si on veut ou un
endroit pour justement en faire quelque
chose de cette souffrance-là et puis ce
qui s'est passé c'est justement par le
faible d'abord des encouragements par le
fait de tout d'un coup pouvoir me rêvais
autre chose que ce petit gars malades
triste un peu un peu différent donc il y
avait un espace tout dédié pour ce qui
était la littérature donc oui ça m'a
permis de renaître sous divers avatars
aussi puisque mon travail qui étendra
sur l'identité réactif toujours un
nouveau à l'infa rock est un peu comme
un tintin qui recommencent à chacun où
astérix à chaque épisode c'est à dire on
peut réactiver s'en passer et sans
avenir juste une espèce de machine si on
veut qu'ils qui surgit le temps le temps
d'un livre on peut dire que c'est votre
semaine parce que bon vous êtes
finaliste pour le prix des libraires on
vient d'apprendre ça êtes-vous passé
samedi dimanche au salon du livre de
montréal ont cisco toujours facile les
salons de livres pour les auteurs c'est
peut être éreintant mais comment vous
anticipez tu sens pour moi disons le
confinement était pas mal plus long que
celui de lakovic donc ça fait comme huit
ans que je le sens confiné en écriture
2000 secret mais le danger donc de
revenir avec un roman comme ça puis de
sentir depuis deux mois
enthousiasme du public donc ça me
remplit de joie que j'ai très très très
hâte de les retrouver samedi dimanche et
au palais des congrès à leffard merci
beaucoup c'est un plaisir merci edward
se disait qu'en fait son cousin était
plutôt la lampe d'aladin le génie
c'était lui